back in march twitter suspended the  account of the massively popular  christian satire site the babylon b  after it awarded man of the year honors  to rachel levine a trans woman serving  in the biden administration's department  of health and human services who had  been named one of usa today's women of  the year the babylon b's editor-in-chief  kyle mann says that the article was  intended to satirize media treatment of  identity politics not demean trans  people we love trans people and we love  you know we don't we don't consider  people like that beneath us you know the  christian worldview is  that everybody everybody has the  opportunity to be saved you know and we  can love everybody and i'm no more  deserving of god's grace than a  transgender person  but  when the culture bows down and starts  handing out trophies to people for stuff  like this is when we say hey wait a  minute we need to protect women in our  society as well